bienvenue dans le quartier d'affaires de
shanghai benoît gauthier et le président
d'interloire tour le syndicat des vins
de loire durant quelques jours ils
sillonnent shanghai ses boutiques ses
restaurants et ses bars à vins objectif
comprendre la commercialisation et la
consommation des vins au sein de cette
mégalopole qui traduit l'envol
économique de la chine n'est valoir on
en trouve heureusement d'ailleurs dans
une palette très large sait on a trouvé
ce matin dans une boutique
do rayonnages quand même de vins de
loire on a aussi un regard sur la
manière dont est perçue mais est ce
qu'il ya une mode sauvignon est ce
qu'une mode chardonnay et une botte
barroso rouge pour optimiser la
diffusion des vins de loire en chine
interloire travailler avec une agence de
communication shanghaïenne dirigée par
un français serge allègre est installé
en chine depuis 17 ans sa mission capter
les prescripteurs professionnels comme
les restaurateurs et les cabistes mais
aussi et surtout les médias en
organisant entre autres des wine dinner
sa mission est difficile puisque en
chine 80 % des vins consommés sont
chinois et pourtant les vins de loire
ont une carte à abattre les vins la
loire ont leur place ça reste des vins
qui sont typés et qu'on est en train de
parler encore une fois de notion de
terroir et les chinois au fond cette
notion de terroir donc on fait souvent
des parallèles avec le thé par exemple
les chinois sont prêts à dépenser sur
des vins importés entre 100 et 150 kw
donc on est en train de parler de 10 à
15 euros est en fait les chinois et les
vins de la loire ton exactement dans ce
segment là si le palais des chinois
semblent séduits par le terroir et
ligériens l'exportation elles restent
difficiles les vins français doivent
suivre un circuit administratif
compliqué avant d'être servis sur les
tables chinoise